[Musica]
oggi vi voglio parlare così è se vi pare
dell'importanza dei dati perché spesso
mi capita di vedere sui social di tutto
e mi verrebbe veramente da dire il dato
così è se vi pare ma a volte mi
trattengo che mi conosce soprattutto
ragazzi che mi hanno imitato qui sa che
sono apolitica e apartitica e che sono
una che di fatto è vero si basa molto
sui dati pur essendo classicista perché
ritengo che siano una fonte di
informazione molto rispettosa nei
confronti del pubblico perché non puoi
mentire e il dato non lo puoi
trasformare a tuo piacimento e quindi io
oggi vi farò degli esempi prima di
andare alle mie conclusioni allora
l'impennata dei prezzi la cosiddetta
inflazione inflazione 10 secondi di
spiegazione è quando c'è un
surriscaldamento dei prezzi cioè i
prezzi salgono il nostro salario no e
quindi un problema
e questo è il dato istat che ho usato
anche a sky
6,7 per cento a marzo 2022 non sarà
questo il dato di aprile ma ci fermiamo
sul dato di marzo
lo vedete o sono
6,7 per cento eccolo qua allora questo è
un dato è il dato di istat che calcola
l'inflazione su un paniere di prodotti
quindi misurano il prezzo eccetera che
cosa ci dice questo dato se io dico 6,7
per cento uno mi dice è quindi che cosa
vuol dire 6,7 per cento rispetto
all'anno prima
molto difficile spiegarlo no non si può
capire facilmente
con questo grafico pro si capisce che 2
per cento
di solito la faccio breve è quella
crescita che ritenuta sana per
l'economia ok perché un po i prezzi
devono crescere già qui non è molto
normale qui siamo veramente considerate
che negli stati uniti siamo sopra lotto
non si vedeva questo rialzo dei prezzi
da quando c'era ronald reagan presidente
quindi veramente molto elevato questo
grafico però aggiunge un altra
informazione al telespettatore
cioè mi dice
che qui da gennaio a marzo
l'accelerazione è più ripida perché c'è
stato il conflitto in ucraina
ovvero c'è molta meno disponibilità
delle materie prime quelle che ci sono
tutti se le vogliono accaparrare e sono
disposti a pagare tantissimo per averle
ed ecco che salgono i prezzi
infatti il dato che cosa ci dice ancora
questo che il 65 per cento di questo
prezzo è composto dall energia e quella
che sta salendo
il resto sono altro
quindi il dato si è letto bene queste
risposte ce le dà perché non è che io
posso dire a e il dato è cresciuto per
colpa del faccio un esempio un qualsiasi
stato lo si potrebbe dire francia
germania o qui del governo attuale no
non è così
il dato è anche frutto di un cambiamento
a livello geopolitico economico che ci
porta ad avere questa situazione altro
esempio
per non parlare appunto di casa nostro
preso come esempio il dow jones che ha
vissuto un primo trimestre dell'anno
indice azionario di borsa americana
preso in considerazione da tanti
ovviamente perché quello più importante
lo vedete questo è un una giornata del
31 marzo in cui il calo era del un punto
percentuale e mezzo
considerate che questo è niente rispetto
a cali che ci sono stati nel primo
trimestre dell'anno è stato un primo
trimestre bruttissimo ok a volte con
picchi che ricordavano la pandemia al
ribasso se io andassi in onda dicendo
disastro caporetto
vittime allora innanzitutto le vittime
purtroppo ci sono state non sono quelle
del mercato azionario quindi bisogna
sempre trattare queste cose con molto
rispetto mettendole nel contesto
innanzitutto e perdita quando tu vendi
se non vendi non è perdita per e ti
conservi finché appunto ven
il secondo guardate come cambia proprio
e guardando ai dati
e che se io guardo il livello di aprile
e il livello di marzo guardate siamo ben
al di sopra qui infatti io andavo in
onda dicendo l'indice sta perdendo ha
vissuto un primo trimestre dimenticare
però occhio è che siamo ancora su
livelli ben superiori rispetto a quelli
dell'anno scorso perché la realtà è che
nel lungo termine le azioni guadagnano
questo è altro esempio che il penultimo
a questo è il più bello allora questo
però è importante ragazzi io mi rivolgo
a voi che siete il futuro
perché io che mi rifiuto di vedere i
talk show ormai lo so ma che va in onda
in realtà quindi dovrei un po guardarli
però su una molto da da televisione
diciamo straniera ma facciamo l'esempio
di un talk show uno che dice siamo
cresciuti tantissimo molto più della
germania e l'altro che risponde ma no è
la germania che è cresciuta di più
il conduttore dovrebbe con la
conduttrice dovrebbero dire guardate il
dato eurostat
il dato il cup dice questo ed è per
questo che è importante che i
giornalisti siano preparati e sappiano
leggere i dati perchè altrimenti andiamo
veramente a carte quarantotto
i dati sono lì e che cosa ci dicono ci
dicono che nel 2021 siamo cresciuti più
della germania 6 e mezzo per cento la
germania 2,9 per cento ma nel 2020 noi
siamo scesi del 9 ci manca solo che non
cresceva modeste e mezzo dovevamo
recuperare questo quindi se vogliamo non
è manco stato un rimbalzo è stato un
rimbalzino positivo è positivo ma un
rimbalzino che sarebbe proseguito
quest'anno se non ci fossero state
queste incombenze e soprattutto dovute
al rincaro iniziale delle materie prime
che era già partito per il lock down
finito lockdown tutti ripartono tutti
hanno bisogno di quelle materie prime ma
non ce ne sono abbastanza per tutti poi
c'è stata anche la guerra e questo stato
il problema però il pil della germania
nel 2020 guardate
è certo che è cresciuta meno però
guardate quanto è scesa meno nel 2020
queste questo è il dato eurostat misura
il pil e quindi qui non c'è da dibattere
o da avere un'opinione
uno può chiedersi perché questo è perché
questo mai dato questo è appunto così è
se vi pare
i dati così
altro esempio ultimo prima delle
conclusioni
questo
questo lo preferisco allora
31 marzo putin avete sentito parlare del
decreto putin era quella conferenza in
cui putin diceva da domani stop al gas
in europa
l'indomani che cosa succede e il
gasdotto yamal che uno dei gasdotti che
dall'ucraina arriva al tarvisio in
italia per poi è per poi appunto andare
nelle nostre case nelle nostre imprese
ha smesso di funzionare ma il gasdotto
yamal smette di funzionare calado sport
res non è e sempre ok sempre non perché
putin ha parlato il giorno dopo ha
smesso di funzionare
apro una parentesi yamal è uno dei
gasdotti che pompa meno gas all'europa
quindi in realtà sarebbe dovuto dire
anche questo
quindi i titoli dei giornali dei
quotidiani che dicevano basta finito
andatevele a ripescare perché per
carineria non li ho messi finito non
stanno pompando più gas basta non era
veritiero non era veritiero se si andava
a vedere il primo aprile il giorno dopo
il discorso di putin il grafico
bloomberg si vedeva che i flussi di gas
che arrivavano dall ucraina in italia
giornalieri erano sui massimi da
novembre
2021 la russia sta continuando a pompare
gas
e per questo a marzo si è portata a casa
10 miliardi di dollari quindi non è che
non sto pompando gas sta pompando gas
che cosa ce lo dice un grafico compilato
dagli analisti di bloomberg quoti
quotidianamente quindi questo è
importante dirlo perché questo dimostra
che i dati ci offrono delle risposte
infatti se noi abbiamo a vedere
l'articolo del 30 marzo di
reuters
dice le forniture di gas russo in europa
occhio che stanno rallentando perché
yamal smette ancora di funzionare prima
del discorso di pontinia male smette di
funzionare sempre quindi questa è
un'informazione veritiera perché ti dice
che ogni tanto yamal smette di
funzionare questo è importante perché
quando noi ci informiamo
dobbiamo partire dai dati e partire dai
dati è molto faticoso
perché una cosa che io arriva in
redazione e vedo un articolo di giornale
mi fermo al titolo e scrivo il pezzo
vado in onda un'altra e andare su
istat.it e andare su eurostat punto it e
andare sul fondo monetario
internazionale sulla banca mondiale
altra cosa poi è mettere in paragone
tutte queste stime per cercare di dare
ulteriori informazioni che amare le
fonti chiamare istat e dire come mai
dato è così qual è stato il rincaro che
avete trovato maggiore rispetto al resto
questo è un lavoro
e costa fatica molto più semplice a
replicare le catene di sant'antonio sui
social oppure fermarsi al titolo e fare
tutto un panegirico sul titolo
insegnando il giornalismo a chi magari e
sul campo ucraina è molto semplice fare
così molto più difficile informarsi mi
rivolgo a voi ragazzi perché c'è un
problema grave dei social quindi se voi
non avete la fatica di andare a
informarvi partendo dai dati
noi avremo sempre più un problema
se invece uno fin forma conosce la
realtà ne ha meno paura può andare a
esercitare un informazione sana e neutra
sui social costa più fatica però si
riesce ad arginare anche quel movimento
di haters che certamente non fa bene
alla nostra comunicazione né tantomeno
alla nostra vita quotidiana e quindi il
compito è vostro dovete informarvi in un
certo modo per poi informare voi stessi
perché avete dei diritti e dei doveri e
dovete essere ovviamente informati
e soprattutto anche la vostra cerchia di
amici la vostra famiglia e un giro
positivo un circolo positivo che genera
altrettanta positività ed è per questo
che ho scelto questa frase che quella
dipinge mente cioè lei che l'ex premier
britannico e statista nota ovviamente
che dice un politico usa i dati come un
ubriaco e lampione non per la luce ma
per il sostegno in ogni tanto mi chiedo
come mai non sia usata questa frase
perché secondo me dice tutto perché
questa frase è rivolta a tutti noi è
rivolta a voi e vi sta dicendo guardate
che se voi non siete informati il
politico ma chiunque un docente non è
che pensa comunque a informarvi sempre
in modo veritiero dovete essere anche
voi a leggere ad incuriosirvi siamo in
un paese dove vige questo bruttissimo
dato che noi abbiamo come primato ovvero
l'analfabetismo funzionale noi dobbiamo
combattere questa piaga quindi questo
questa frase rivolta a voi in tal senso
ma è rivolta anche a me perché mi
insegna che bisogna sempre imparare a
mettersi in dubbio di fronte a un dato
anche a cambiare idea a operare un
giornalismo per cui io non porto la mia
opinione ma vedo un dato è medico dove
ho sbagliato
torno indietro e cerco di cambiare il
mio ragionamento non è un errore non è
un fallimento e fare la cosa giusta
perché io non sono alle dipendenze della
mia azienda ma di chi mi guarda del
telespettatore quindi verso di lui verso
di lei ho un dovere morale o un dovere
da cittadino e da giornalista di
informare e so che il giornalismo è
molto bistrattato in ogni cena 6
giornalista il male della società
italiana
grazie a tutti per essere qui
invece io so che bistrattato e mi
dispiace
però io posso parlare per me perché so
che in parte anche un po colpa nostra io
guardo alla mia esperienza quello che
faccio tutti i giorni svegliandomi alle
quattro e mezza del mattino e io so che
per quanto sia malvoluto quest'oggi e
bistrattato io so che posso riportare le
persone a sentire i giornalisti ea
leggere i giornalisti solo in un modo se
do le notizie con integrità
partendo dai dati e vuole sa se tu
grazie